so we've been given the value of h of x
at a few values of x and then we're told
james said that since h of 7 minus h of
over 7 minus 3 is equal to 1. so this is
really the average rate of change
between x is equal to three and x is
equal to seven between that point and
that point right over there so since
that is equal to one there must be a
number c in the closed interval from
three to seven for which the derivative
at that value c is equal to one
so what james is
trying to do is apply the mean value
theorem which tells us
if the conditions apply for the mean
value theorem
it tells us that
if i'm going through two two values
so let's say this is a let's say this is
b
and let's say the function does
something like this
if we meet the conditions for the mean
value theorem it tells us that there's
some c in the closed interval from a to
b
where the derivative of c is equal to
the average rate of change between a and
b so the average rate of change between
a and b
would be the slope of the secant line
right over there
and then we could just think about well
looks like there are some points the way
i've drawn it that point right over
there seems to have the same slope this
point right over there has
seems to have the same slope and so
that's all what the mean value theorem
is claiming that there's going to be at
least one c if we meet the conditions
for the mean value theorem where the
derivative at that point is the same as
the average rate of change from the
first endpoint to the second now what
are the conditions for the mean value
theorem to apply and we've reviewed this
in multiple videos one way to think
about it if we're talking about the
closed interval from three to seven one
condition is that you have to be
differentiable
over
the open interval from 3 to 7.
so that's the interval but not including
the endpoints and you have to be
continuous
over the entire closed interval so
including the endpoints and one
interesting thing that we've mentioned
before is that differentiability implies
continuity so something is
differentiable over the open interval
it's also going to be continuous over
this open interval and so the second
condition would just say well then we
also have to be continuous at the
endpoints
now let's look at the answers so it says
which condition makes james's claim true
so we have to feel good about these two
things right over here in order to make
james's claim
choice a
h is continuous over the closed interval
from three to seven
so that does meet this second condition
but continuity does not imply
differentiability so that doesn't give
us the confidence that we are
differentiable over the open interval if
you're differentiable you're continuous
but if you're continuous you're not
necessarily differentiable classic
example of that is if we have a sharp
turn something like that we wouldn't be
differentiable at that point even though
we are continuous there
so let me rule that one out so i'm going
to rule that one out
choice b h is continuous
and decreasing over the closed interval
from 3 to seven
no that doesn't help us either because
it still doesn't mean you're
differentiable you could be continuous
and then decreasing and still have one
of these sharp turns where you're not
differentiable so we will rule this one
out
h is differentiable over the closed
interval from 3 to 7.
this one feels good because if you're
differentiable over the closed interval
you're definitely going to be
differentiable over the open interval
that does not include the endpoints this
is a subset of this right over here and
if you're differentiable over a closed
interval you're going to be continuous
over it differentiability implies
continuity so i like this choice right
over here
now this last choice is the limit as x
approaches five of h prime of x
is equal to one
so they're saying the limit of our
derivative as we approach five is equal
to
one
now that doesn't we don't know for sure
this limit might be true but that still
does not necessarily imply that h prime
of 5 is equal to 1. we still don't know
that and you know 5 is in this interval
but we still don't know just from this
statement alone that there's definitely
some c in the interval whose derivative
is the same as the average rate of
change over the interval so i would rule
this one out as well